Speaker 1: We thought it might be happening
and it very clearly is happening.
Donald Trump is scared to debate his fellow
Republican challengers in the 2024 Republican
presidential primary.
He is now using the cover of saying Fox News
is no longer a fair place for him to have
a debate.
As part of the story he is telling about why
he will likely not participate, at least in
the first Republican primary debate scheduled
for August 23rd on Fox News.
Let's be super clear and just call this for
what it is.
Trump doesn't believe that debating will be
good for him.
And I have to tell you, I don't know that
he is wrong.
He is leading the Republican primary by quite
a bit.
And we're going to look at that polling in
a little bit.
If the debates go well.
He would still simply be leading the Republican
primary maybe by a little more, but he's already
winning by enough to win the Republican primary.
On the other hand, if the debates don't go
well, either because he stumbles or everybody
else ganged up on him, make them look stupid,
or they treat him unfairly, whatever.
It can only hurt him.
And so Donald Trump is aware of the fact that
the debates may be a risk to him, given where
the polling is right now.
And now Donald Trump is making this abundantly
clear.
He went on Newsmax yesterday.
He says he doesn't know that he wants to do
any primary debates.
But specifically, he says Fox News Fox News
is now hostile to him and he just may not
do it.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: And you have a hostile network
like Fox, Like when I did the breadth of the
interview with Bret, I thought it was fine.
I thought it was okay, but there was nothing
friendly about it.
You know, it was nasty.
And I thought I did a good job by being given
credit for doing a good job.
But I've also people said, Why would you do
it?
Because it was really, you know, everything
was like an unfriendly.
It was always everything was unfriendly.
No smiling, no.
Let's have fun.
Let's make America great again.
Everything was like a hit.
So here you have a national network and you
have people that are obviously the candidates
are against you and they therefore are being.
So if you're leading, by.
Speaker 1: The way, isn't that amazing?
He's like, also the candidates would be against
me.
It's like, well, yeah, they're running against
you.
Of course, the candidates are going to be
what he wants the candidates to be for Trump
on the debate.
Speaker 2: 30, 40 or 50 points.
What's the purpose of really doing it?
Okay.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, listen, reading between
the lines, you don't have to read between
the lines very much.
Trump is saying, I'm winning now.
I don't really get the point.
It can really only hurt me and it might actually
hurt me.
That is something that actually might happen.
TRUMP then going on truth, social.
Speaker 2: Censure.
Speaker 1: And continuing the attacks, saying,
quote, So Fox News, which is down 37% in the
capital, our ratings doesn't cover my getting
the Man of the Decade award because of my
great trade policies in Michigan or my keynote
speech for Faith and Freedom in D.C. and then
wants me to show up and get them ratings for
their, quote, presidential debate where I'm
leading the field by 40 points.
All they do is promote against all hope.
Ron does sanctimonious and he's dropping like
a rock.
Sorry, Fox News Life doesn't work that way.
How bizarre has the American political scene
gotten?
Trump then continuing to troth apoplectic
glee quote Fox News just covered from beginning
to the end the Ronda sanctimonious, very boring
news conference at the Capital B border, but
didn't cover one minute of my two big speeches
on Saturday and Sunday night.
One for faith and freedom in D.C., the other
about trade in Michigan, where I was presented
with the Man of the Decade award, the dissent.
This speech was just a rehash of all the things
I did to have the safest and strongest border
in U.S. history.
Also, I'm up on him by 40 point points and
also up big on Biden.
Bottom line, folks, Trump is afraid to debate,
and it seems as though he is not going to
participate.
The first debate scheduled for.
Let's see what we have here.
Politico has a guide to the first presidential
debate in the primary.
The highly anticipated debate is going to
take place August 23rd at Pfizer of Pfizer
forum in Milwaukee, where the RNC is going
to be held in 2024.
Fox News will host the event, outlined specifics
on Tuesday.
Bret Beyer and Martha MACCALLUM will be moderating.
And you know, it's going to be on fox news
and we'll have more information as we get
closer.
Trump indeed may not debate.
And if that is the case, I can only imagine
that his supporters will say it is the only
correct decision that could possibly be made.